so we came from there to here to go to  Europe to get a better life - to get  education to sit and leave such a human  beings but we now now we are here I  don't know what to do we are not having  the chance to go back or to forward we  are now like a gel here is like a gel  for us we cannot find for ourselves  twilit we cannot sometimes come that we  cannot buy a bottle of water we don't  like to stand in Greece we want to pass  we want to pass the Greece we want to go  to the country that they need us then  they need us we we don't like to want  free money we will go there we will get  education we will work hard we will  improve the earth we will also work with  them together they should accept as a  human dish that we can be an in a safe  place  that is our demands that everyone  demands as you can see nor all of them  the people are young all of them are  young why they are trying to pass the  borders they need in a comfortable peace  life